hey everybody happy 2017.
Best news ever the CW renewed all of the TV
shows.
So all the superheroes is a coming back.
I'll explain what's going on they aired this
epic promo reel.
So let's go there is a new round of the flash
ring giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything.
Oh my God this is so excited just to clarify
to the new Constantine animated TV show was
not the brand-new show.
The Geoff John's was teasing that's going
to be something else.
So we'll talk about that when they announce
it.
So going down the list, so legends of tomorrow
probably going to double down on Legion of
doom.
Obviously, the team is plug and change the
little bit.
The Legion of doom will probably cycle its
roster to probably some more black siren.
Maybe some more justice society character's
and just a society storylines from the comics
because vixen is on the team citizen steel
is on the team.
So I'm expecting them to stay heat wave will
see about Sara is probably deftly going to
stay on the team Ray Palmer will probably
stay on the team, but there's always like
one or two people that might get cycle dinner
out the other new characters that they could
introduce on legends of tomorrow will be Constantine
because they said they would love to bring
them back on legends when the opportunity
arises but they're doing so many characters.
This season.
The just wasn't an opportunity for him, so
expect Constantine to come back for the live-action
shows next season.
Maybe he'll even be a part of the big four
night crossover, but the basic way that they
billed the seasons will stay the same like
though still travel around to different periods
of time can do all kinds of trouble while
they're chasing down the Legion of doom, so
one of the big question is is what about the
reverse flash.
I would be willing to bet that there still
going to be like a big flash villains leading
the Legion of doom, so hopefully that's the
reverse flash just like looking forward to
like another big villain like Grodd or someone
crazy joining the Legion of doom as well.
So next on the list Supergirl season three,
what the probably do is still keep her earth
in a different universe that they can do Supergirl
Superman stuff and they don't have the it
like really crazy with the way they explain
Superman on earth one, but here's the thing
Supergirl in the Legion of superheroes Mon
El is a big Legion character Supergirl was
a big Legion character for little while but
they haven't really done a Legion of superheroes
story line yet they tease the Legion ring
in the Fortress of solitude during Supergirl
season one.
But that's about all we've gotten so far,
so if you haven't read the comics.
The Legion of superheroes is from like the
very distant future and it's basically like
a giant team up there is a version of brainiac
on the team.
So I would be surprised if they do some Brainiac
stuff but I'm also expecting Legion of superheroes
at least make some sort of appearance maybe
during the big four night crossover because
they said they already had the idea for like
with the next big four night crossover's going
to be this time they'll be a little more integrated
because this year there was really just like
the end tag typically took like a piece of
the flash episode contacted on to the end
of the Supergirl episode, so expect more from
the Supergirl crossover later this year and
here's the thing to do because the Justice
league movie is getting ready to drop at the
end of November this year.
When this crossover would get ready to air
like this there's usually the beginning of
December.
So because they're happening around the same
time just expect like a little bit of parody
that doesn't mean that they won't be able
to use Superman, but just expect some more
Superman stuff to be happening I'm expecting
him back before the end of the season for
like a brief appearance, but there's still
a lot of big rules about using those big Justice
league characters on TV I would not be surprised
if wonder woman also gets teased on Supergirl
to like a version of wonder woman even if
they just make a reference to her or just
makes an offhanded remark but if there's any
TV show that the gonna tease wonder woman
on it would have to be Supergirl, just because
it's a female lead show and she is also similar
power levels so it just makes sense next big
show arrow season six so not a huge surprise
arrow pre-much as the steam at this point
to make it through season seven beyond season
seven really just depends on what the ratings
are, and whether or not the actors want to
keep making it because they just renew supernatural
as well, which is an like it's 15 billion
season so they can keep making that then obviously
that's like the benchmark for returning series
so as long as arrow is rated higher than supernatural.
They will continue to renew arrow storyline
though like what is going to be the big arc
for arrow season six.
You know they still haven't finished season
five yet the still of this Prometheus stuff
is happening, but like I said my Prometheus
video he's tearing Oliver down preparing him
for a green arrow rebirth like a rebirth in
the comics so season six of your tentatively
calling green arrow rebirth.
If you haven't read that arc in the comics
is really just like returning the character
to his core values Geoff John's did a big
rebirth for pretty much every character in
the DC universe in the comics it was great
but I know you are asking like what new big
characters from the comics the gonna do during
season six.
Marc Guggenheim has said that they are working
up to the question is like I would love to
do the question we been teasing hub city which
is where the question comes from the one obviously
there's always like a lot of new characters.
They do from the comics there doing Talley
all cool shall probably come back in season
six but I'll also save the biggest new characters
that we know right now will probably be the
question, but because of all the drama with
the suicide squad on TV do not be surprised
if they do some more suicide squad stuff in
season six just depending on how big he gets
that like a Superman.
On Supergirl situation to because there's
a big suicide squad movie franchise just don't
expect them to be able to do every single
character is they billed into season six season
seven also don't be surprised if they do other
spinoff word of the team ups like you things
that are big enough that they could be their
own shows in their own right like birds of
prey that something we haven't quite got to
on arrow yet teen Titans would be like another
one or like a live-action young justice situation
just more storylines that you feel like could
serve as the basis for a spinoff TV show,
but number one of course the flash season
for, nobody is surprised that he got renewed.
It is literally the CW's highest rated show
of course is going to get renewed.
They renew pretty much like every single returning
series with a few exceptions what about the
storyline.
Everyone is like whose can be like the new
big villain is going to be another speedster
is going to be a non-speedster.
So what will happen this season is that they'll
wrap up their savitar storyline and like all
big villains like the black flash at the end
of season two he'll probably just go off and
be sidelined for little while.
So they can come back for some big adventure
in the future but the one big thing that we
definitely know there going to do is more
flash family so we have new speedsters Wally
West and Jesse quick and Jay Garrick Jay Garrick
is really that new he kinda started during
season two so will all come back they could
always decide to introduce a new speedster
beyond that like the always be new speedsters
on the show, but there like court characters
and then there are characters that you only
see very briefly like the flash of verse 19
the accelerated man.
We don't really know what his future.
On the show is because they do so many different
things each season.
They go to different earth when keeping with
that tradition.
The also visit different earth's of the multi-verse.
So will see more different versions of the
flash we might see the Daniel West reverse
flash.
We might see that he is thought I think what
will definitely happen is is the black flash
will make a brief appearance even if it is
a part of the big arc like the flash is been
teasing this big future war what they might
decide to do in the future season is a version
of the war of light only.
The light will just be like the different
colors of all the speedsters lightning.
So you have like evil reverse flash family
team up versus good flash family team up because
we do have enough members of the flash family,
that they could do like a big group fight.
So I feel like that's mostly building into
defeating savitar at the end of the season
and in the future you could just have like
the good flash family fighting a team up of
evil flashes.
So what I'm in a do.
Next week is I'm in a do like a flash season
for early predictions for storylines and characters
that they could do so if you have any questions
about storylines or characters that you want
to do bonus videos about just let me know
in the comments, it's still gonna be a couple
weeks before all the shows come back they
come back on the 23rd.
So what can happen is all still be doing the
flash ring giveaway.
Make sure you turn alerts on so you don't
miss any of the videos this can be all kinds
a bonus videos before that happens it's gonna
be awesome and we have to talk about the animated
Constantine.
So if you guys didn't know CW seed is like
a different streaming service that they have
been doing of vixen animated show is a bunch
of episodes that are about five minutes of
peace they didn't say exactly how many episodes
of animated Constantine.
There is going to be or how long the episodes
are going to be they did say that Matt Ryan
is coming back to voice the character so it
will be the Constantine that you remember
but they didn't say whether or not it's going
to be a continuation of the original Constantine
series I'm assuming.
Not just because they can be as crazy as they
want.
So they'll be continuity with the other CW
series but maybe not with the original Constantine
series, so was can happen later tonight is
I'm in a do some more comic book stuff then
I'll post my Sherlock video in the morning
just a been a minor schedule change.
So get hype is can be so awesome this year
while you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for the trailer for the next episode
of the flash.
You can click here for the arrow trailer thank
you so much watching I'll see you guys in
the next video!